- [Interviewer] Alright,
Master J and Little Mama.
Where are you guys from?
- Well, I'm originally
from Galveston, Texas.
Been out here pretty much all my life.
I've been all over California.
From--
- [Interviewer] Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in Inglewood, California.
- [Interviewer] And Master J,
where are you from originally?
- I'm from Ohio.
- [Mark] And so, Little
Mama is one of your girls?
- This is my bottom.
- [Interviewer] It's your
bottom, bottom bitch as you say?
- That's right.
- [Interviewer] And how
many girls do you have?
- I had, at most, it's five,
right now, I only have three.
- [Interviewer] And how
did you guys grow up?
How did you grow up Master J?
- Well, I grew up homeless.
Well, I grew up with single parent.
And I, you know,
I just wanted to find
out what was going on.
I went, you know, found some
friends and then went across,
you know, I had my first
hole at the age of 13.
They were 16 years old.
You see what I'm saying?
I used to have them go
up in the school bathroom
and turn tricks and give
me their lunch money
and whatever else they have.
- [Interviewer] And where'd you learn
that was a possibility at 13?
- I met a pimp out down there on Figueroa.
He was my family took me under his wing.
I needed extra money coming,
my mom couldn't get me
everything she had, you know,
I wanted, I had big dreams
and she couldn't fulfill it.
And so I wanted to help the household.
And that's where he got
the idea that right there.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been doing it ever since?
- I've been doing it ever since.
- [Interviewer] So the
arrangement Little Mama
is what you give Master
J all of your money?
- Pretty much.
I mean see I don't mind
giving him all of the money
because he also when I
give him all the money
he gives me money too.
Like for myself.
- [Interviewer] He takes care of you?
- Yeah, so pretty much,
you know I give it to him because he
you know is in control of
you know making sure we
have food and clothes and toiletries
and stuff like that
because we're homeless,
you know?
- It's what you call it,
I'm just a business manager right there.
I'm not a pimp, I'm not a player,
I'm just a business manager, what it is,
I make sure she had what she need
with what she did.
She earned.
I just get a percentage of what it is.
You see what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] And if she gets in trouble
with one of her tricks?
- I am the one--
- [Interviewer] You come in, you step in--
- Yes I also have
associates to handle such.
- [Interviewer] So you're
a little bit of protection
for her as well?
- Most definitely.
No one messes with Master J's girls.
- [Interviewer] Have you done prison time?
- Excuse me?
- I will not answer that question.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
and if Little Mama gets
arrested, which is not such a--
- She's well taken care of.
- [Interviewer] And how
much will you make a night?
Little Mama?
- It varies.
I may like on a slow, slow on a slow day,
it's like five to, to a rat.
It's like five to a thousand
but I make like 1,500
to 2,000 dollars a day.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
Have you had bad experiences
with some of the guys that pick you up?
What kind of stuff has happened?
- I mean, I've had them
play games with me.
I mean, you know, I don't know
what their intentions are,
but like to be honest with you
I did a date, the other day,
for a couple of hundred dollars.
Right and you know come
to find out they were all
fake twenties.
- [Interviewer] They were
paying you with fake money?
- So I wasn't you know
it kind of pissed me off, but
I guess that's how life is.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been doing this since how long?
- I've been pretty much all my life.
- [Interviewer] What age did you start?
- I started like, okay,
I'm thinking because I had
my son at the age of 18.
So I pretty much got out
there at 19 years of age.
And I'm 43 now.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about how you grew up,
you had both parents?
- Well the thing about that is that
they divorced when very early.
So I was always moving around.
You know I went from staying
with mom to staying with dad
to staying with grandma,
you know, having, you know,
step parents and you know, so, I mean,
I can't say that I was,
I was poor, you know,
but it, I wasn't born with
a silver spoon in my mouth.
- [Interviewer] Any abuse
when you were a kid?
Does it go sexual anything like that?
- No.
- [Interviewer] And Master J,
what personality traits do you
have that help you do this?
Not, not everyone can be a pimp, right?
- No everyone can be a pimp.
No, what you have to do with,
see I'm more of like of service.
I like to consider
myself just to, you know,
service to the public.
There's a lot of lonely men out there.
It's a lot of people
that likes to come in,
you know what I mean, men and women,
and I've always been a people person.
So what I do there is I just, you know,
get them what they need,
what they can't find on their own,
you know, just to bring joy in one's life.
That's my mind.
I've got the top, you
know, my babies, you,
as you can see, very beautiful.
I don't, I don't have nothing under that.
You know if they ain't a 10
I don't want to work with them.
- [Interviewer] And
what's, what is your style?
I've talked to a lot of pimps
and some are ladies men.
They're smooth talkers
some guys are a little more aggressive.
- It's not.
I would consider myself
as just being a realist and a freestyle.
I'm a free spirit, man.
You know, you have your choice.
You know, I give you the opportunity,
you know, the opportunity to
do something for yourself.
I like them to go to school.
I like them to do their thing.
It's all about them.
It's all about bringing
them up, picking them up,
not tearing them down.
See, what I'm saying, you know,
I done had a couple, you know,
I worked with for maybe a
year or something like this.
And they got out of the game
they went to school
while they was doing it.
And now they, you know,
professional career women.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
the relationship between a pimp
and a prostitute is sometimes a recreation
of the father daughter
relationship that a lot
of these women had or didn't have?
- That's a good question there my man.
But the thing is a lot is you have a lot
of lonely women out there
that want that father figure
you see what I'm saying,
but you, you know,
you have to balance it out.
Yes, I'm dad, but I'm also your friend.
You feel me?
And yeah--
- [Interviewer] You're
their business manager,
you're their boyfriend,
you're their daddy,
you're everything.
- That's it right there.
They have to be all things in one.
I'm your superhero.
I'm all of that in one.
- [Interviewer] You guys have children?
- Not yet.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- No we don't.
- [Interviewer] You guys
been in love before?
- Excuse me.
- [Interviewer] Have you been in love?
- We're in love now.
We was in love at first sight.
- And yes I just wanted to make a comment,
as far as that pimp
and prostitution thing,
it can be a together thing,
you know, but you know,
there's also cases where it's
like, you know a separate,
a separate thing, because
like one for themselves,
but that's not the case here.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
a part of the picture
for you guys?
- It was once.
And it all depends on what you call drugs.
See alcohol is a drug so
it all depends on what
you call a drug.
Never got into anything heavy, you know,
drink some you'll find
someone that liked to
do you know this or that.
We'll put it that way without
incriminating ourselves.
- [Interviewer] Little Mama,
do you find being a little high
helps you do this every day?
- Yeah I mean, I'm going to keep it real,
we're trying to survive period.
Point blank.
You know what I'm saying?
You know, we have to,
we don't have any, you
know, paperwork or anything.
So we have to try to keep a room.
You know what I mean?
We have to eat, we have to,
so it all goes together.
It all goes together with
that there, you know?
I mean, sometimes there's
drugs sometimes there's not,
sometimes yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you
guys are basically living
from hotel room, to motel room?
- Yeah we try to we pretty much try to get
to the same place and get a room every day
- [Interviewer] And do
business out of that room?
- I'm kind of, that's really for us.
So I have to do my
business like around it.
But like I say, we're trying to survive.
We are trying to survive.
That's honest, you know, we're
looking for we're trying to,
we talk and we're trying to make
up plans for other, you know, resources.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think you're addicted
to this lifestyle?
- Who?
- [Interviewer] Either of you?
I mean, do you think this
lifestyle is addicting?
- Yeah it can be very addicting.
And I'm glad that I'm
at the point where I'm
pretty much over it.
- [Interviewer] You're over it?
- Yeah I'm ready to just
do some normal things.
- [Interviewer] What was
the best time of your life?
- When was the best time life?
Well, I've had, you know,
I guess a few different
times that that's kinda hard.
That one's kinda hard.
- [Interviewer] What was
the worst time of your life?
- The worst time?
- Being separated from your family.
- Oh, being separated from my family.
- [Interviewer] Are you
close to your family today?
- I'm trying to be.
- [Interviewer] Does your family
not approve of what you're doing?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Do you
get depressed at times?
Little Mama?
- Yeah, yes.
- [Interviewer] It's a rough
way to spend your days, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think most squares
don't understand about the game?
What do outsiders not see?
- That it's one of the oldest professions
in the world and it's to bring joy.
They look down when they
look down on, you know,
on my business associates, you know,
it bothers me, you know?
And I just say, it's for their enjoyment.
I mean, it's, you know, they, you know,
like they, they dirty, but they're not.
They bringing joy, they out to bring joy,
you know, at they expense,
you see, but a square,
always gonna look down until they get bit.
Once they get bit by that forbidden apple
then they more like hey
they spend more than the banker.
- [Interviewer] Is sometimes
not exactly just sex for money.
Sometimes you're getting the watch
or the jewelry or the wallet
or something like that.
Money from the guy.
Does that happen?
- I mean, it has, you know,
but it's not really about that.
I mean, don't get me wrong.
You know there are good
times where you don't
have to really, I don't have to.
I be with someone and
they'll spend money on me
for a while and I'm not,
I don't even do anything.
- [Master J] Just to have
company see did to be event.
A lot of men out there, this
one, somebody to talk to,
have a pretty lady on their side,
they fantasize in their
head and they go home
and their wife or their
boyfriend or whatever.
- [Interviewer] What was the
craziest thing you've seen
in your years of doing this?
- [Master J] Oh my, my, my, my.
Well, I seen, I seen why on both ends.
I seen, you know, I seen
women get mutilated.
None of my business associates is
but I've seen other
women getting mutilated.
I've seen men get tore up.
I, you know, it's just, I mean, it's wild.
That's why you have to pick and choose.
And I always ask my
associates just don't jump
in any car on a, you know, on a dream.
Just don't jump in any
car, be picky, be choosy.
You see what I'm saying?
'Cause you know who knows
a psycho could be a past.
- [Interviewer] Little Mama do you find
you have to use your intuition
sometimes with customers?
Are there guys you'll just say no to?
- [Little Mama] Yeah, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How has the game changed?
You've been doing this for awhile,
the flashy dressers and the
fancy cars and all that--
- Yeah,
and I mean it's a widespread
I mean the way the cost
of living and all that with
everything has changed economy.
- [Interviewer] Technology too?
- Yeah it's changed now.
You know the women is
getting much younger,
to where that's where I come up
with going out of state, you
know, state to state, to state,
you know what I'm saying?
'Cause it's just getting and
and the drugs have a lot to do with it.
The addictions is driving
a lot women out there.
You have a lot more Renegade
women out there, you know,
so called working for their
own, decide to act, you know?
And it's just, it's not
the same as the old days.
- [Interviewer] You guys
will travel to other states?
- Yeah, we've been, we've
been places, but we,
but you know, on business,
but we yet to go, you know,
like you said, we, we come
down to our retirement days.
Now it's time to kick back
little picket fence house
with a picket fence,
lots of kids.
- [Interviewer] Alright,
Master J and Little Mama,
thank you so much for talking with me
and good luck with where
ever you guys go from here.
- And thank you for having us.
- Thank you very much.
- [Master J] Show me the money.
- [Little Mama] Oh God.